give me your thoughts what do you think
about the influences that have been
involved in promoting FTX
what's so fascinating too about this
recent week with the FTX Fiasco and the
pushback and seeing all the I read the
comments so I see comments and videos
all throughout YouTube
and I think everyone's to blame right if
there's any fraud that goes on if
someone promotes something right if you
go to your neighbor and say hey you
should buy a house it's a great time to
buy real estate the second they buy the
market crashes in their house is worth a
hundred thousand dollars less like yeah
yeah in a sense you should be blamed a
little bit even though it's not entirely
your fault so there'll always be blamed
to give out what I find interesting is
is where they're pointing the blame and
also just the
um just the unfortunate nature that
people were sponsoring something that
was a complete fraud without them
knowing and so the to me the real
question is did people know it was a
fraud or a scam and still promote it
that's where my ethical line is drawn in
the sand why do you think that your
position in coffeezilla's is different
on this we actually agree to a large
extent I think we were just disagreeing
on like some points that aren't really
that relevant for instance here's a
great question so he brought up the idea
of Tom Brady's not a financial expert
Steph Curry is not either so you don't
go to them for financial advice right my
position is they were getting paid let's
just assume 50 million right for Tom
Brady dude to do what he did is probably
I mean he'd have to get paid some
serious dough my guess is he probably
got paid somewhere in the 30 to 50
million range which means he's probably
influencing that much right any business
sense will tell you there they had
reason to believe whatever they paid him
they make back at least one to one and
so
who's really at fault if if Tom Brady's
not a financial expert and people aren't
going to him for financial advice I
totally agree on that point right if you
go to a financial YouTuber there
absolutely is is more responsibility on
them I've never argued that my point is
that Tom Brady influenced at least 100x
to a thousand X the damages and so if
we're being reasonable people here and
let's figure out where to place the
blame my point is that if someone caused
a thousand next person a causes a
thousand extra damages as person b a
reasonable person would place the blame
more on person a they both deserve blame
and that's what I said in my video and
what I want to bring it up is how
interesting it is to see the feedback
and this is where I get to like the
public sentiment and the negativity is
that I was being incredibly reasonable
even said you can blame my friends they
are partially to blame here this is not
like a new this is not like an argument
I was trying to fight against it's
absolutely true my point is that I
believe there were other factors at this
there were other people that are just to
blame and then coffee Zilla also brought
the point that so and so is not an
expert because this happened right well
if we use that same logic then anyone
who invested in this company is not an
expert I would like to consider
BlackRock Sequoia capital and these
other massive funds as experts I will
not change my position on that because
of FTX nor does anyone nor does anyone
change their opinion so why now are you
changing the opinion of someone who
influenced them does that make sense it
does does it not make sense also to say
that if you push something which
ultimately turns out to be a scam that
your validity and how much Faith people
should have in you goes down a lot
absolutely you should absolutely
question it and now you should wonder
what's next right if if someone were to
promote a scam or a fraud and the next
thing they promote is something similar
I would say major red flags that's not a
good look right I I understand the
approach that you're taking which is
kind of like a utilitarian thing there
is a total pot of damage that has been
done in terms of every influencer that
contributed to FTX we should be
um proportionately putting our Vengeance
and our displeasure toward those that
did the most but when you're referring
to most of the content that's going out
at the moment it's going out on YouTube
it's specifically being aimed at
YouTubers and given the fact that it is
on a platform that these people exist on
Tom Brady doesn't have a YouTube channel
he is not a YouTuber first and foremost
YouTube has every right to point fingers
at members of its own community and say
you've done [ __ ] up we're gonna make
everybody know that this is this is
something that was a huge error on your
part as somebody that claimed to be a
financial expert
I absolutely agree and yeah I never
disagreed with that point at all it's
like if uh if you went on Tom Brady's
website right you're probably going to
see comments about Tom Brady for this
situation you're not going to see
comments about Graham Stefan right so I
totally get that argument my point is
that you can lead because all this comes
down to it's almost all click bait right
like a lot of the venge a lot of
thumbnails is like a little sensational
and you know so-and-so is a scammer
they're the worst person ever right I
get it it's Sensational my point is that
you can make videos about these people
on YouTube 100 that's a smart thing to
do I would do the same thing if I was
talking about something that happened
with YouTubers I'm going to put the
YouTubers in the thumbnail my point is
that throughout the video you then bring
out a reasonable argument that contains
what I'm saying right so you start with
the YouTubers they're at fault however
you then introduce the fact that there
are many other factors in this but I
think if you only target three or four
individuals to me that's dishonest and
that's where I came from and that's why
I responded the way I did when I don't
think something's fair I'm going to
mention it you'd mentioned that you're
friends with a bunch of the guys that
are kind of culpable at the moment I
think you're on the same management
company create a creators agency yeah
code yeah they get a sponsorship deals
is that jading your view of these people
at all is that causing you to be less
unbiased with your approach
do you think we are capable of
understanding our biases
to a degree
you think so yes I think that it's your
job to discount
the
position that you hold based on what you
think your biases would be about those
people so like if someone starts
criticizing my roommate and best friend
I I know that there is going to be a
part of me that is going to immediately
stick up for him no matter what the
criticism is but I need to account for
that it's my job to think I'm close to
this person I have a ton of biases that
are playing with this so if I want to
rationally look at this which is what
you're proposing you're proposing we
take this rational utilitarian view how
much damage is being caused overall that
is absolutely something that needs to be
turned inward on yourself when you're
saying okay
just how biased am I when it comes to me
talking about my friends and and
co-creators within this agency
I agree so number one this is why I
bring up that I'm friends with them
throughout the video so I don't I make
it very clear that you can assess that
however you want right I feel like it
would be disingenuous if I didn't bring
up that point and then I was trying to
play like oh yeah I barely know them
when in fact I do I also by the way I
put my I put creators agency email in my
thumbnail or in my description and I
have all pictures all over my Instagram
it's like it's kind of funny people are
trying to expose this as if it's like
very public so yes I'm so I'm attached
to them but also we're discounting the
fact that I teamed up with them because
I like them in the first place and I
think they're good people who doesn't
dude I eat dinner with these guys every
Tuesday I hang with them for hours you
don't think we discussed this stuff
that's unfortunately what doesn't go
into YouTube videos is you don't see the
hours behind the scenes where I actually
talk to them about FTX and anyway I've
also in regards to bias I think the best
way to challenge a bias is to bring up
an identical scenario but you remove the
emotions meaning let's do the exact same
scenario but it's let's replace the
people where you may have a bias towards
in this case my friends let's replace
them with random people let's call him
Tai Lopez Grant Cardone and all these
people had they promoted FTX here's the
thing I'm very very very confident that
my position would not change obviously
you can believe whatever you want to
believe you don't know me as well as I
know myself the story is Sam Bateman
freed right when I look at stories I
like talking about fraud I like talking
about things that have been proven to me
the story is SBF and how we fooled
everyone and how we fooled some of the
smartest Minds in the world additionally
I would have talked about the
influencers who were at fault for
influencing this
the problem and the reason why I made
the video I did is I would not be making
a sensational title in making the video
only about them the story is Sam bakeman
freed and maybe halfway through the
video I'd bring up Tai Lopez Grant
Cardone Influence People
to
lose money let's in the most simple
terms right they influence people to
lose money are they at fault yes but I
would have began the story
with all the people who I believe are
way more at fault and so am I biased of
course it's so funny am I biased of
course I am but also in the same video
coffee cell is the one person like I
respect him more than anyone he's
probably my favorite Creator and I
disagree with him even knowing by
disagreeing with him that I'd cause an
emotional response I could have easily
put clips of his in the video and just
not disagreed and like made the made
people not react the way they did and so
am I biased yes but I also felt like I
was more than fair because I'm defending
friends and I'm actually going against
the one person I respect the most like
we have similar audiences way more than
say like a Graham Stephan or Andre dick
and so I was essentially going against
The Narrative of my own audience and so
when people ask if I'm biased well sure
we all are to some degree but that's
taking away from the fact that I kind of
stuck my neck out knowing that there'd
be a massive negative response
and I still made the video I didn't have
to make the video
so that's my answer I think that one of
the concerns people have one of the
difficult positions that anybody in the
call out space the grift scam
identification space has
people feel like the policeman that
breaks the law is doing something that's
particularly egregious because they're
the ones that are supposed to live by
the law they enact it right and it's
kind of like you guys are the police of
the internet in a way it's like somebody
steps out of line we're gonna find it
we're gonna do a video on it and
everybody's gonna laugh at them and call
them a wanker
that means that you get held to the
highest level of scrutiny of anybody and
it the concern I think is that if you're
supposed to be on the side of holding
people who promote scams accountable
this should be applied in the same
degree of intensity toward everybody
that was a part of FTX
wholeheartedly agree by the way that's
the best argument presented towards me
and one that I actually very much
appreciate when people challenge me like
that because I totally agree the thing
is in my video I say that you can place
blame on them I'm not saying don't place
blame I'm saying everyone is at fault
the argument I present is just to have a
weighted scale so for so we don't argue
in circles here because because I said
weighted scale what I was really trying
to say is you can blame person a and
person B just send a little more of the
Vengeance energy towards person a if he
caused way more damages but yeah I
totally agree man what level of scrutiny
do you think influences should go
through when they do a partnership like
this obviously one of the questions that
we're talking about is how foreseeable
was this in retrospect it seems
completely obvious in advance it seemed
almost completely unobvious
how much
work do you think
these influencers should do to work out
whether or not what they're promoting is
legit
I think step one of this kind of the
first question I think transparency is
always best right if if someone was
emailing them the whole time just saying
I have secret Intel do not promote this
product it is bad and you still do
yeah a little more burden of proof is on
you to show that you're not the bad guy
here so I think it's always important to
come out and just share like what
exactly happened from your perspective I
see nothing wrong if you were duped as
well
I think it's important to talk about it
and not shy away from it
and let people know that you were duped
as well I think what's important is that
you question
you can always question people it's
always fair to be questions that's why
I'm always open to criticism I'm totally
cool with people making videos about me
say whatever you want you can question
my reputation credibility standards of
Ethics yeah whatever totally cool with
everything it's there's I've never had a
problem with people criticizing or
making videos simply questioning and so
in a situation like this
when there is a scenario where you
influence people to lose money I think
you absolutely should have your whole
operation questioned and I think what's
most important is now to see how they
respond right
in a time of Crisis I think how you
respond tells you everything you need to
know if you begin promoting let's say
crypto altcoins or something after this
Fiasco or begin promoting
another crypto exchange probably not a
good look even if it is reasonably safe
and so I think that's um that's where
you question first and then you evaluate
the behavior after if the behavior after
doesn't change
I think you then can attack with the
Vengeance I'm seeing today I think
that's the fairest way to do this well
that's kind of what we were talking
about at the beginning right that there
is
there is obviously a lot of distaste at
the moment on the internet and the
closest people that can be touched and
that a lot of the internet feels like
they can impact literally the guy that
everybody is trying to find no one knows
where he is on the planet right we don't
know where sandbankment freed is so he's
currently off the table people can send
all of the tweets that they want but
nobody feels like they're actually going
to impact sunbankment free today like
he's already having a pretty bad day
right
the people that most of the internet
that do have discussed at what happened
with the FTX tobacco
the ones that they feel like they can
apply some pressure to
are the creators of the size of a Tom
Nash or a Graham Stefan or whatever and
the reason that they're putting pressure
on them is because they think that they
can make some sort of a change that
they're going to appear within their
mentions that someone's going to send
them the video or whatever
and they know they'll be heard right
that's most important if BlackRock had a
comment section would we see the same
energy I don't know I'm not sure but you
can't access them you can't access Tom
Brady you technically can respond to his
Twitter or something or his Instagram
but he's not going to read it he's not
going to see it yeah so this is the
front line
of the of the pushback and that's why
and look this is what we sign up for I
can't really complain right whenever you
do get pushback it's like we get the
glory we get the the fun life we get the
you know for some of us the money
extreme levels of money and uh and we
get a lot of benefits and then when
something happens yeah I think that was
another coffee criticism it's like you
can't have your cake and eat it too yeah
I totally agree like I'm when you when
you sign up to sponsor something you're
kind of putting your reputation on the
line and I think when something goes
wrong you do take a hit for sure yeah
that's why I would be hesitant to say
um you get like a life you get like a
you're allowed to have one of these
errors within this domain but then if
you do it again then we're gonna come
after you it's like no like [ __ ] 10
billion dollars of money has been lost
like you don't get to you don't get to
get that get out of jail free card it's
like oh it's only a mistake if I make it
twice I I I I don't think that's a
strong argument
my argument that is no just that if that
was what was being put forward I don't
know if that's precisely I think that's
not exactly what you're saying but the
degree of scrutiny that people should go
through about their
the companies that they are partnering
with is that's a really interesting
question like how much due diligence are
you supposed to do presumably BlackRock
did a fair bit of it but then we also
see situations like the SoftBank and
wework one where they also did and
continue to pump tons and tons of money
in so you know that humans have these
biases where a charismatic owner or
someone that's got a great story or
whatever can encourage people to spend
more money than they should do and okay
well just how much time and effort uh
should be spent on this and where's the
threshold right like you say if it was
an obvious [ __ ] coin well what's an
obvious [ __ ] coin like if you've got
selling gravity and promoting like a
fundamental lore of the Universe on one
side and promoting an absolute [ __ ] coin
on the other at what point you are no
longer liable for something going wrong
like if you promoted the US dollar right
which done all right over the last year
if you promoted the US dollar and it
went down like how culpable are you for
that like it's an interesting question
to look at where that line lies and I
think that the internet at the moment
seems to suggest that it lies below
where most of these influences are I.E
that they are culpable for pretty much
everything that's happened
yeah I think that's a fair argument
here's where I come in I like to look at
intentions of behavior in all scenarios
I try to evaluate the best I can I think
that matters most like what are your
real intentions right if your intentions
if you're promoting an altcoin some of
these all coins and it's incredibly
likely that they're going to pump and
dump right and especially those who took
money right before a pump and knowing
there was going to be a dump your
intentions are clearly to take money at
the expense of your audience I think
that's an entirely different argument
than someone who takes money right so
you're both taking money to promote
something but an option two you'd
legitimately think and have reason to
believe that your audience will benefit
from the product or service you're
promoting
in regards to the due diligence that's
such a fascinating argument because we
have an inherent level of trust in
everyone right like you assume BlackRock
did due diligence but now in my point
about like the week the week following
you're gonna find all these these red
flags right there was some story about
Sam Bateman and fried in a meeting where
he was trying to raise money he's like
playing video games and and eating
snacks it's like that that is incredibly
a large red flag however there's
probably 100 examples of someone in a
very questionable manner in a in a
fundraising meeting and yet it turns out
to be the most legitimate thing in the
world that's why I'm saying there's
there's like there's not a single in
life there's never like a single thing
that you can point to that goes there's
an obvious fraud or problem
and I can spot it from the start it's
like you can find examples that's why
life is so nuanced
yeah it's challenging what would you do
if you were one of the influencers that
had been involved in this what would you
do moving forward
well first off thankfully I didn't
promote it that's a thankfully yeah I
purposely stayed away from crypto
anything crypto related man I'm not into
crypto space it helps that my audience
is not crypto related so it it kind of
gave me that easy out right just
anything crypto let's stay away
I think the first thing is you you are
incredibly transparent about the process
you went through to figure out that it's
legit Because by the way I've had
conversations with these guys behind
closed doors that no one knows about
like they've done way more due diligence
than the average person and this is by
the way this also goes into my video
that I make that unfortunately people
just don't see which is you don't think
I've talked to them about this stuff
over dinner
it like they know way more there's my
buddy the Tom Nash is another one he I'm
not gonna explain but he he had a very
trusted source that like let's just
leave it at he had every reason to
believe this was an incredibly
legitimate company way more credibility
his source is way more credibility than
the average audience and so anyway I
think it's important to share all that
you know if you can share how much money
you made and typically it's best to
share the process on how you're going to
improve so you first show empathy
towards the people who lost money you
second share complete transparency about
everything you went through or
even all the benefits you had from it
are you gained and just say this is
really unfortunate and then most
importantly you show that you're willing
to improve
from what happened I think that's the
best case scenario but I've also but
full disclosure I've never experienced
something like that I've never gone
through like a media Scandal and so I'm
I'm just from my perspective that seems
to be the best case like whenever you
see people handle it really well that
seems to be the process they follow yeah
it's an easy uh sideline tactic I think
but when you're in the midst of it
someone's saying I got paid 50 Grand a
month or whatever from FTX meanwhile all
of the people watching are 50 Grand down
you know on their investment I I haven't
seen I don't know whether Tom's done a a
video about this yet I've seen maybe a
couple of the ones online there is a
uh like a a tone to finance YouTube
that's a bit dispassionate
like it doesn't really feel like there's
a massive amount of emotion going in
there it does sometimes feel a little
bit like a press release that's coming
down from a an office on the 45th floor
and I do think that you're right that
you know genuinely showing empathy not
just reading lines that sound like
empathy but genuinely showing empathy is
important I also don't think that I've
seen anybody disclose how much money
they were paid for this partnership yet
so uh I would say that given your
tactics
as of yet no one's followed any of them
yeah I agree yeah that's a really
uncomfortable conversation right is you
got paid for work and you got let's say
let's just call it a fair market rate
and then when that thing goes wrong like
do you give the money back here's the
here's the thing like yes you all in a
perfect scenario you just I got paid
five grand to do this and I'm gonna give
five grand of these homeless puppies
down the street right now oh my God
you're the good guy here but what
happens when it's you know a decent
amount but you did it for so long that
you know you have you're worth something
too you're putting in work and giving
value to the world other than the
sponsorship right and the sponsorships
help you pay your bills and and help you
produce the content that hopefully is
helpful outside of the sponsorship right
yeah what is your responsibility in
making people whole that is an
incredibly tough ethical question and
something that I'm not really going to
speak further on because I don't want to
position my friends as doing the right
or wrong thing because everyone's that's
theirs that's their fight I'm not in
this so you know what would I do
yeah and by the way I think it totally
changes if you get paid a thousand
dollars and you've got a lot of money
you're probably just gonna pay it off
just hey I'll give it up but you know
what happens if my my net worth is X
what happens if I'm getting paid
you know a significant amount from that
sponsorship and now I'm not liquid right
if whatever I got paid if I'm not liquid
that or if it's gonna massively damage
my life you know where's the ethical
line between giving and by the way
what's also challenging about this is
the variable that you can't account for
is that just by giving the money away
let's say that doesn't mean that
everything's made right
you're not you maybe didn't even save
your reputation so that might not even
be the solution right you you might if
you if you gave away the funds you might
help out your your cause in the moment
but is that angry mob that's coming
after you are they gonna be fine with
that and agree that that is an adequate
follow-up to what happened or are they
still going to be just as angry
ultimately that's an incredibly
challenging question ultimately what
people want to see is someone that looks
and sounds and genuinely is sorry about
what's happening what's happened to
everybody what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face
[Music]